the United States is facing a refugee
crisis that's being called anything but
that thousands of unaccompanied children
from Central America are crossing into
the u.s. and getting stuck inside a
system that is as unprepared as it is
overwhelmed so why are these kids coming
into the United States and how is the
government responding in 2014 President
Obama said the country was facing an
urgent humanitarian issue he was
referring to the almost 102 thousand
unaccompanied children who were expected
to approach the us-mexico border by
August 2014
about 11,000 in June 2014 alone and
about 75 percent of them were coming
from Guatemala Honduras and El Salvador
so why would this be a refugee crisis
and not just an immigration headache
because it's not just poverty the kids
are escaping and it's not just family
that they're coming to join according to
a 2014 UNHCR report 58 percent of the my
grandchildren interviewed reported
having suffered or been threatened with
serious physical harm Guatemala Honduras
and El Salvador are in the world's top
five countries for homicides this means
these kids are migrating to survive and
that means under international law they
could qualify for international
protection and asylum and this crisis
isn't slowing down in 2015 the number of
children migrating from Central America
has only increased in October and
November of 2015 10,000 children crossed
the us-mexico border twice the amount of
children crossing during those months in
2014 so how exactly is the United States
responding to the crisis well we're
still trying to figure it out in Central
America the US government is running ad
campaigns that tell people that the
journey to the north is too dangerous
in September 2014 President Obama also
approved a plan that would allow
children living in Central America to
apply for refugee status while remaining
in their countries this is of course
intended to discourage their migration
but of the 4,600 kids who applied only
11 have gotten refugee status the u.s.
is also paying the Mexican government
tens of millions of dollars to restrict
people whether from Mexico or Central
America from crossing the border and
Mexican authorities were for a while
successful but when kids do get to the
US what happens
well Mexican children are turned away at
the border and Central American children
are taken into Border Patrol custody
Border Patrol then hands them over to
either Homeland Security or to the
Health and Human Services Department
where the Office of refugee resettlement
takes over oh our our has a few thousand
beds in shelters across border cities
where the children will stay for usually
around 30 days before they're either
placed with a family member in the US or
placed into foster care from there the
kids enter an overwhelmed u.s.
immigration court system those lucky
enough to have lawyers receive better
outcomes and some don't ever make it to
court of the kids who do show up to
court almost 80% are allowed to stay but
they're not given legal status they're
not refugees and they're not given
juvenile visas in other words once their
case is closed they're just not actively
deported they're left in a sort of limbo
so if the sheer numbers of kids
continuing to flee to the US when is it
time for us to start calling this a
refugee crisis
you